[Musik]
wir fördern die energetische Sanierung
den beschleunigten Einsatz von
erneuerbaren Energien in Gebäuden
ab 2024 wenn wir jedes Jahr 500.000 neue
Wärmepumpen installieren
wieder so ein Wumms 500.000 neue
Wärmepumpen verspricht der Bundeskanzler
für 2024 wir haben fragen wer genau soll
das bezahlen wer soll diese Wärmepumpen
installieren und wo willkommen liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer zu diesem
Phönix plus wärmepumpen sind ein
wichtiger Faktor der Energiewende keine
Frage allerdings beim Einbau ist
Deutschland bislang Schlusslicht in
Europa
20036.000 Wärmepumpen wurden im Jahr
2022 installiert das ist noch nicht mal
die Hälfte von 500.000 und das war vor
dem Heizungs-
und die Verunsicherung bei allen
Beteiligten befeuert wir wollen in
dieser Sendung etwas Druck aus dem
Kessel nehmen und hinschauen was wir von
unseren Nachbarn lernen können welche
Rolle Fernwärme und kommunale
wärmeplanung künftig spielen und worauf
Mieter und Wohneigentümer innen jetzt
achten können denn auch die um Sicherung
zeigt sich bereits in Zahlen 2023 wurden
deutlich weniger Förderanträge für
Wärmepumpen gestellt als im Jahr zuvor
erstmal abwarten wie sich die Preise und
Fördermöglichkeiten entwickeln
Hausbesitzer einzelne Ibrahim aus
Stockdorf bei München hat seine
Wärmepumpe schon Lieferzeiten von bis zu
einem Jahr das war einmal wir merken auf
jeden Fall dass auch jetzt schon Kunden
Aufträge zurückziehen dass Kunden
skeptisch sind was gar nicht nur eine
neuen Förderung sondern auch einfach an
der generellen Unsicherheit liegt die
dieser hin und her mit der Gesetzgebung
jetzt verursacht hat der Ampel Streit um
das heizungsgesetz hat die Kunden
offenbar verunsichert die Nachfrage nach
Wärmepumpen ist eingebrochen im August
wurde die bisherige staatliche Förderung
zurückgefahren danach haben sich die
Anträge im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
nahezu halbiert
5 Milliarden Euro hat die Branche in den
Aufbau der Produktion gesteckt
befürchtet nun dass sich der negative
Trend verfestigt noch arbeiten die
Hersteller die alten Aufträge ab durch
die Verschiebung des Gesetzes fehlen
ihnen aber nun verlässliche
Rahmenbedingungen und damit
Planungssicherheit
das war eventuell zu viele Mitarbeiter
aufbauen oder zu wenig Mitarbeiter
aufbauen und dann wieder in
Lieferschwierigkeiten kommen und das
bedeutet dass wir bei unserer
Liquiditätsplanung sehr genau hingucken
müssen ist macht uns das Leben etwas
schwieriger der Absatz von Öl und
Gasheizungen dagegen hat sich zurzeit
fast verdoppelt viele Verbraucher
erneuern Sie noch schnell setzen noch
nicht auf die energetisch sinnvollere
aber hochpreisige Wärmepumpe
Wärmepumpen gelten als beste Lösung um
den CO2-Ausstoß beim Heizen zu
verringern das Ziel der Bundesregierung
500.000 Geräte pro Jahr zur Zeit scheint
das jedoch in weiter Ferne
ja darüber müssen wir sprechen mit Frau
Professorin Lamia messari Becker sie ist
Expertin für Gebäudetechnologie und Bau
Physik an der Universität in Siegen ich
grüße sie dahin
hallo ja also bei ihrem Ziel den Gebäude
Sektor klimafreundlicher zu machen und
weniger abhängig von fossilen
Brennstoffen zu sein hat die
Bundesregierung ja sehr stark auf das
Thema Wärmepumpe gesetzt sich regelrecht
drauf konzentriert setzt sie damit auf
das richtige Pferd
sie setzt auf jeden Fall auf einem
wichtigen Baustein der wärmewende
allerdings wir hören dazu noch viel mehr
Optionen also die Wärmepumpe alleine
kannst du nicht richten wir brauchen
noch weitere Optionen jetzt mit der
kommunalen wärmepläne werden diese
Optionen auch vor Ort
klargestellt und wenn wir noch die
Förderkulisse noch dazu bekommen dann
geht es auch eine also eine größere
Sicherheit jedenfalls für die Bürger und
für die Unternehmen welche Optionen
wären da vorstellbar
vorstellbar wären neben der Wärmepumpe
die ja auch nicht immer nur eine ein
Gerät ist sondern das gibt
unterschiedliche Energiequellen für die
Energie für die Wärmepumpe also Luft
Grundwasser oder Erdwärme das kann man
natürlich entsprechend der Situation
einsetzen zusätzliche gebe ist natürlich
die Möglichkeit über Brennstoffzellen
über
Verbrennungstechnik mit
klimaneutralen Energieträgern also
Stichwort Biogas Biomasse darüber hinaus
geht es natürlich auch Lösungen bis hin
zur Fernwärme die man natürlich im
dritten Maßstab einsetzt wichtig ist
dass wir eben nicht nur strombasierte
Heizungen also die Wärmepumpe sondern
auch beispielsweise wärmebasiert also
geotherme Bio was Biomasse Abwärme
industrielle ab beim Abwasser dann
müssen wirklich alles nutzen was nun
geht um diese wärmewende hinzubekommen
also die Expertin für Gebäudetechnologie
setzt auf verschiedene Bausteine damit
man auch flexibler ist sie haben mal
gesagt Frau Professorin die soziale
Akzeptanz ist eigentlich die wichtigste
Währung bei der Klimapolitik haben wir
aus ihrer Sicht aktuell ein Wärmepumpen
die Lämmer
na wir haben insbesondere nicht darauf
geachtet dass die Strompreise natürlich
eine große Rolle spielen wenn eine
Wärmepumpe insbesondere insbesondere bei
luftfahrtbasierten Wärmepumpen an
bestimmten Tagen zu einer Stromheizung
mutieren ist Problem gebe ist nicht bei
Erdwärme was ihr die wärmepunkt aber
trotzdem wir haben insgesamt das Problem
dass sie Energiepreise sehr hoch sind
und die Bundesregierung muss
beschleunigt dafür sorgen dass das
Energieangebot auch
erweitert wird also nebenausbau von Wind
und Photovoltaik müssen wir dringend
eine diversifizierte Energiewende
voranbringen das bedeutet
biothermie das bedeutet Biogas das
bedeutet Biomasse alles in Maßen das
geht natürlich auch nicht überall aber
wir brauchen all diese Energiequellen
und dazu gehöre ich natürlich auch die
unterschiedlichen Technologien damit wir
möglichst viele Menschen mitnehmen
können und viele Gebäude versorgen
können erneuerbar und man darf natürlich
auch vergessen man darf nicht vergessen
dass wir auch die Gebäude sanieren
sollten damit wir den Energiebedarf
insgesamt senken und darüber über diese
Maßnahmen sollten wir mittelfristig auch
günstige Energiepreise hinbekommen für
Bürger und Unternehmen vielen Dank Frau
Professorin bis dahin wir sprechen
gleich noch mal weiter
Schatz ich habe uns eine Wärmepumpe
bestellt was sollen da die Nachbarn
sagen möglicherweise haben die da
nämlich tatsächlich ein Wörtchen
mitzureden denn Wärmepumpen arbeiten
nicht geräuschlos und wie soll es in
Deutschland auch anders sein es gibt
natürlich ganz genaue Vorschriften wo
das Gerät aufgestellt werden darf da
geht es um Abstände eben zu den Nachbarn
und um noch so allerlei denn so genau
die Vorschriften auch sind so
unterschiedlich sind sie in den
verschiedenen Bundesländern
Harald van de Sand ist genervt vor
anderthalb Jahren lässt er sich eine
Luftwärmepumpe installieren mit dem
umweltfreundlichen Heizsystem möchte er
einen Beitrag zur Energiewende leisten
und auf lange Sicht Heizkosten sparen
mit dem was dann passiert hat er nicht
gerechnet
ein lieber Nachbar hat sich beim Bauamt
darüber beschwert über diese Wärmepumpe
obwohl die Wärmepumpe noch nicht im
Betrieb war dann ist mir bin ich
aufgeklärt worden dass wir eine
Privatstraße haben und das der Abstand
nicht eingehalten würde laut Bauordnung
es geht um Abstände und um Lärmschutz
denn mit der wachsenden Zahl an
Wärmepumpen wächst auch die Angst vor
dem dauerbrummen aus dem Nachbargarten
kein Wunder wünscht sich doch
Wirtschafts- und Energieminister Harbeck
bis 2030 hierzulande 6 Millionen
Wärmepumpen das geltende Baurecht für
Wärmepumpen und Klimageräte ist stand
heute aber kompliziert wir haben in
Deutschland die Situation Region dass
wir nicht eine Bauordnung haben sondern
16 Landesbauordnungen und deswegen ist
es auch so das bezüglich der
Abstandsregelung der Abstandsflächen
jedes Land eine eigene Regelung hat
deswegen muss man hier wirklich mal
genau reinschauen ja wie viel Meter
brauche ich denn eigentlich dann zur
Grundstücksgrenze um eine Wärmepumpe
aufstellen zu dürfen der Mindestabstand
zur Grundstücksgrenze beträgt je nach
Bundesland mal einen mal zwei mal drei
Meter doch aufgrund der wachsenden
Nachfrage wird Abstand halten zum
Problem vor allem bei Reihenhäusern mit
schmalem Grundstück sind 3 Meter gar
unmöglich Reformbedarf
von daher gibt es um auch hier etwas das
dieses Thema ein bisschen zu
beschleunigen Bestrebungen diese
Abstandsregelungen zu ja zu verändern
dahin gehen das ist halt also keine drei
Meter mehr sind sondern ebenfalls noch
ein halben Meter Harald van der Sand
wohnt in Nordrhein-Westfalen in einem
reinen Eckhaus die Wärmepumpe lässt er
von Heizungsbauer Jürgen Küppers auf dem
Dach der Garage installieren so kann er
mit den Anschlüssen sofort in den
Heizungskeller zum Zeitpunkt der
Installation sind in NRW 3 Meter Abstand
Vorschrift
drei Meter Abstand wurde von mir
eingehalten alleine durch diesen Weg der
dazwischen ist mit 4,50 m und dann habe
ich mir keine weiteren Gedanken darüber
gemacht doch obwohl es sogar sieben
Meter bis zum Nachbarhaus sind gilt der
Abstand zur eigenen Grundstücksgrenze in
diesem Fall knapp zwei Meter fande Sand
muss eine Ausnahmegenehmigung beantragen
mit der Folge also ich praktische
Bauantrag stellen muss dass ich ein
Lärmgutachten machen muss und so weiter
und so fort
auf Wegen gegenseitiger Rücksichtnahme
um Lärmschutz geht es in erster Linie
denn brummt demnächst in jedem Garten
eine kann das für ganz schön Radau in
der Nachbarschaft sorgen wichtig ist
dass man auch das
Bundesimmissionsschutzgesetz einhält und
hier ist ganz relevant in welchem Gebiet
befindet sich eigentlich mein Haus ist
es ein Gewerbegebiet es ist ein
Mischgebiet oder ist das ein reines
Wohngebiet denn hier sind auch die
Anforderungen unterschiedlich hoch das
geltende emissionsschutzgesetz ist
bundeseinheitlich und gibt klare Grenzen
vor
dürfen die Geräte in kerndorf und
Mischgebieten tagsüber nur mit 60 und
nachts mit maximal 45 Dezibel Brummen in
allgemeinen Wohngebieten und
kleinsiedlungsgebieten liegen die
Grenzwerte bei 55 und 40 in reinen
Wohngebieten wie bei Harald van de Sand
nur 50 und 35 Dezibel zur Orientierung
30 Dezibel sind vergleichbar mit
leichten Windgeräuschen eine ruhige
nächtliche Wohnstraße erzeugt um die 40
Dezibel und 55 Dezibel sind zu messen
beispielsweise bei Regen genau wie eine
Luftwärmepumpe denn die liegt in einem
Meter Abstand gemessen bei 40 bis 60
Dezibel die zu erwartende Emission
sollte aber im besten Falle vor der
Installation berechnet werden
wenn wir ein Angebot machen für einen
Kunden müssen wir irgendwelche Sachen
fiktiv erstmal annehmen und da hilft uns
halt eben der entsprechende
Schallschutz Rechner den wir haben nach
dem Wärme
Wärmepumpenhersteller verwandt und ich
sag mal in 95% der Fehler passt das auch
wer ist später überprüfen mag kann dies
in einem Abstand von einem Meter tun die
nächtliche Emission kann direkt am
Nachbarhaus gemessen werden wichtig
vorab bei der Wahl des Aufstellortes
natürlich sollte man jetzt auch eine
Wärmepumpe nicht jetzt direkt unter dem
Schlafzimmerfenster platzieren man
sollte auch ein gewisse Abstände dann
auch einhalten man sollte auch
gegebenenfalls schauen dass man eine
Wärmepumpe gegebenfalls auf den Sockel
stellt und gegebenenfalls auch noch mit
ein Haus damit dann einfach nicht zu
viel Schall entsteht man sollte auch
darauf achten dass eine Wärmepumpe nicht
zwischen zwei Mauern installiert werden
weil das natürlich dann erst recht
Schall erzeugt
ist dem Nachbarn die Pumpe dann noch zu
laut gibt es weitere Möglichkeiten dass
mein entsprechenden Abstand zur
Wärmepumpe versucht da irgendwas zu
machen also entweder mit mit einer
Holzwand oder mit entsprechender
Bepflanzung entsprechend groß das hilft
in der Regel schon massiv und wenn man
ganz ehrlich ist selbst E-Autos die
draußen vorbeirauschen die werden lauter
sein als die Wärmepumpe die nur noch vom
Haus steht sollte es weiterhin
Schwierigkeiten geben bieten
Verbraucherzentralen und Mietervereine
Hilfestellung bei Harald van de Sand
beweist das Lärmgutachten jedenfalls
dass alles stimmt und er hat Glück in
NRW ist die Landesbauordnung über einen
runterlass bereits geändert ab 2024 muss
es offiziell nur noch ein halber Meter
Abstand zur Grundstücksgrenze sein auf
den Kosten für den Nachbarschaftsstreit
bleibt er wahrscheinlich dennoch sitzen
das GEG das Gebäude Energiegesetzes gilt
ja schon seit 2020 für alle Gebäude die
beheizt oder klimatisiert werden neu ist
jetzt das Kommunen wärmeplanung
vorliegen müssen bis 2028 haben sie
dafür Zeit Großstädte zwei Jahre weniger
für Privathaushalte gilt jede neu
eingebaute Heizung soll zumindestens 65%
mit erneuerbaren Energien laufen für
bestehende Heizungen ändert sich
zunächst nichts allerdings gibt es eine
Obergrenze ab 2045 sollen Gasheizungen
verboten sein ökologisch macht das Sinn
schließlich entfallen auf Gebäude über
ein Drittel des Energieverbrauchs in
Deutschland die Missionen daraus müssten
um mehr als 40% reduziert werden um die
Klima Schutzziele zu erreichen bis eben
20 30 dennoch ist die Sanierung einer
Bestandsimmobilie eine kostspielige
Angelegenheit und bevor man sich für
eine Heizungstausch entscheidet braucht
es Zeit und einen kühlen Kopf
bei Gregor weil von Haus und Grund
Frankfurt stehen die Telefone nicht mehr
stillt der Grund das geplante
heizungsgesetz die Politik setzt vor
allem auf teure Wärmepumpen wenn der
Anschluss an einen Fernwärmenetz nicht
möglich ist beim Verband privater
Hauseigentümer sorgt die Ungewissheit
für Unruhe
mit was werde ich eigentlich zukünftig
mein Haus versorgen können mit welcher
Energie das ist auch relativ unklar
Stichwort kommunale wärmeplanung und ja
dass die Verunsicherung groß bei den
Leuten geht es um die private
Altersvorsorge die kommunale
wärmeplanung soll beantworten wo in
Frankfurt die Fernwärme ausgebaut wird
und wie lange das dauert
so lange wollte Peter Paul Thoma aber
nicht warten der Ingenieur und
Energieberater plant deshalb für dieses
Frankfurter Mehrfamilienhaus eine
Kombination aus Gasheizung und
Wärmepumpe eine sogenannte hybridanlage
die die zukünftigen Vorgaben erfüllt
denn eine Wärmepumpe alleine wäre viel
zu teuer
das hat eine relativ hohe Heizlast und
in dem Moment wo es sehr kalt draußen
wird geht die Wärmepumpe in ihrer
Leistung runter und schaltet dann
Heizstäbe dazu und dann haben wir eine
Elektro direkt Heizung und da ist die
Wärmepumpe einfach nicht mehr
wirtschaftlich weil sie dann sehr teuer
ist vom Stromverbrauch her
eine Luftwärmepumpe nutzt die sogenannte
Restwärme aus der Außenluft in mehreren
Schritten erwärmt die das Heizwasser
allerdings wird das Wasser nicht so heiß
wie bei einer Gasheizung an kalten Tagen
wird das bei ungedämmten Häusern zum
Problem damit es trotzdem warm wird
erhitzt ein elektrischer Heizstab das
Heizungswasser zusätzlich und das
verursacht hohe Stromkosten
für Peter Paul Thoma ist eine
hybridanlage deshalb die beste Lösung
meist heizt die Wärmepumpe nur wenn es
richtig kalt wird schaltet sich die
Gasheizung dazu noch aber ist die alte
Heizung drin
es handelt sich hier um eine
Gasetagenheizung wie sie sehr häufig
vorkommen und jetzt kommen diese
Gasetagenheizungen die werden demontiert
sie sehen auch hier ganz oben den
abgasanschluss ja und hier ist quasi der
Kamin und in dem Kamin verlegen wir die
neuen Heizungs-
ein riesiger Aufwand und eine Belastung
für die Miete denn jede der zehn
Wohnungen im Haus wird zur Baustelle
in der Küche jetzt hier wo wir uns
befinden wird eine Staubwand aufgestellt
wir müssen hier natürlich diesen Bereich
zum Teil öffnen so dass wir die Rohre
durchfädeln können die Rohre müssen
vorher isoliert sein und dann halt auch
hier in dem Bereich den Anschluss
herstellen können da muss natürlich
aufgestemmt werden und später wieder
verschlossen werden das ist schon etwas
Aufwand aber wie gesagt technisch
machbar technisch machbar aber auch
ziemlich teuer dabei wurde für dieses
Haus sogar noch eine höhere Förderung
genehmigt mittlerweile wird die
Gasheizung nicht mehr gefördert mit der
Förderung die es noch bis 2022 im August
gegeben hat legen wir bei
14.000 Euro pro Wohnung und die
Förderung würde das jetzt mittlerweile
bei 17.000 liegen rund 140.000 Euro
kostet die Umrüstung auf die
hybridheizung für das 10 Parteienhaus
und das ohne energetische Sanierung
messari Becker ist Professorin für
Gebäudetechnologie und Bauphysik an der
Universität Siegen sie sagt die
Umstellung auf Wärmepumpen in
Mehrfamilienhäusern wenn erforderlich
könnte viele Eigentümer finanziell
überfordern so ein Umbau von dem
Heizsystem eines
Mehrfamilienhauses was eben
Etagenheizungen hatte das ist kein
Spaziergang das ist schon eine
umfassende Maßnahme und die will geplant
werden kalkuliert werden und es gibt es
sogar Einzelfälle wo die Kosten dermaßen
hoch sind dass die Leute sogar darüber
nachdenken eher zu verkaufen als zu
sanieren umzusteigen
hunderte Milliarden Euro wird der
Systemwechsel im Heizungskeller
insgesamt kosten gerade mal rund 1,4%
der jährlichen CO2-Emissionen
Deutschlands sollen damit ab dem Jahr
2030 eingespart werden
aber die Kosten seien nicht einmal das
größte Problem sagt Ingenieurin Massari
Becker viel schlimmer die
strominfrastruktur in Deutschland sei
oft gar nicht auf Millionen neuer
Wärmepumpen vorbereitet
wir rufen die Heizung
alle in wenigen Wochen im Winter in der
Heizperiode und deshalb ist es ganz
wichtig um eine halswende erfolgreich
hinzubekommen parallel die Stromnetze
auszubauen aber der Ausbau der
Stromnetze in Deutschland hängt schon
jetzt um Jahre den Planungen hinterher
und in den nächsten Jahren sollen
Millionen Wärmepumpen zusätzlich ans
Stromnetz angeschlossen werden
bei der Mainova in Frankfurt sorgt das
für Unruhe
der kommunale Versorger befürchtet dass
das die Stromnetze in einigen
Stadtgebieten überlasten könnte
die Plätze sind für diese Aufgabe im
Moment noch nicht vollständig
vorbereitet das liegt daran dass die
Energiemenge die dort transportiert
werden muss viel viel größer ist als das
was bisher sozusagen für die
elektrischen Verbraucher benötigt wurde
das heißt wir werden jede Straße über
die nächsten 15 20 Jahre dann auch
Aufgaben und mit leistungsstärkeren
Kabeln Versehen ein riesiger Aufwand vor
allem in der Innenstadt will die Mainova
deshalb auch die Fernwärme massiv
ausbauen und plant dafür sogar ein neues
Gaskraftwerk
aktuell sieht die Wärmeversorgung in
Frankfurt so aus dass wir 25 Prozent mit
Fernwärme versorgen etwa 60 Prozent mit
Gas und 15 Prozent mit Öl
perspektivisch gehen wir davon aus dass
sich dieser Mix umstellen wird auf 50%
Fernwärme und 50% über Wärmepumpen
allerdings wird für viele kleinere
Städte und Gemeinden die Fernwärme keine
Option sein dann bleibt in den meisten
Fällen nur die Wärmepumpe bis spätestens
2028 müssen die Planungen stehen das
Tempo der wärmewende geben jetzt die
Kommunen vor also da müssen wir noch mal
nachfragen bei der Expertin ich freue
mich dass uns weiterhin zugeschaltet ist
Frau Professorin Lamia messari Becker
aus Siegen die Kommunen wir haben es
eben gehört haben Zeit bis 2028 ihre
Pläne vorzulegen also die Pläne
Klimaziele haben wir auch gelernt sollen
bis 2030 erreicht werden dazwischen
keine großes Rechenexempel zwei Jahre
Zeit reicht das für Bauvorhaben
also die Aufstellung ihr reine Planung
grundsätzlich bis 2028 ist möglich
vorausgesetzt die Kommunen bekommen mehr
Personal mehr Unterstützung vor allen
Dingen auch Wissenstransfer nicht jede
Kommune sollte jetzt vor sich alleine
hin planen sondern es geht darum das
Kommunen sich überregional zusammen von
insbesondere mustergesetzgeber dafür
sorgen dass die Kommunen die nötigen
Daten auch bekommen um die wärmepläne
aufzustellen aber sie haben vollkommen
recht
aufgestellt ist noch nicht umgesetzt ich
würde nur sagen auch eine gute
Vorbereitung ist hier wichtig also
aufstellen ja aber die Umsetzung ist
eine Baumaßnahme und das wird uns Jahre
wenn nicht sogar Jahrzehnte Kosten
trotzdem bin ich optimistisch und sage
die gut vorbereitet ist halt umgesetzt
okay also ruhig Zeit lassen wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe für die gute
Vorbereitung auch wenn man dadurch
natürlich riskiert dass das ganze über
20 30 dann hinten hier hinausrutscht
richtig
wir bekommen aber nach hinten raus merke
Geschwindigkeit wissen Sie wenn wir es
jetzt schaffen das Gebäude eine gewisse
und die kommunale wärmepläne und die
Förderkulisse gut aufeinander
abzustimmen dann mag es sein dass wir
jetzt ein paar Jahre vorbereiten aber
nach hinten raus werden wir schneller
sein und mehr Klimaschutz im
Gebäudesektor vor allen Dingen sehr
vernetzt nicht nur ab am Einzel geworden
sondern in Quartieren im ganzen Städten
wir werden eine urbane Energiewende
hinbekommen und die wärmewende ist eine
infrastrukturwände das ist eben anders
als Mobilität wenn du vielleicht zwei
drei Optionen haben bei der wärmewende
geht es tatsächlich um eine
bundesweite Aktion um heizen um Hals
Energie je nach Region je nach
Ressourcen je nach
Vernetzungsmöglichkeiten mit der
Industrie eben erneuerbar oder
weitgehend erneuerbar war sicher zu
stellen und da reicht auch ein Blick ins
Ausland Dänemark
Schweden haben ja auch jahrelang erstmal
ihre Fernwärmenetze aufbauen müssen und
dann erst haben sie das und Öl nicht
mehr erlaubt das machen wir zu einem
späteren Zeitpunkt in der Sendung
schauen wir genau dahin nach Dänemark
ich würde aber gerne noch mal hier in
Deutschland bleiben bei diesem
angesprochenen Konzept wenn denn was
bedeutet das denn jetzt für die privaten
Haus oder Wohnungsbesitzer ja ich höre
die kommunale wärmeplanung geht bis 2028
soll ich dann erstmal abwarten
vielleicht bekomme ich ja auch den
Anschluss die Möglichkeit mein Haus oder
die Wohnung das Gebäude an ein
Fernwärmenetze anzuschließen
ganz wichtig für Gebäudeeigentümer und
damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur die
privaten großen sondern auch die
öffentliche Hand ich meine auch man muss
an Mieter denken ganz wichtig für diese
Leute ist erstmal zu schauen was hat die
Kommune vor mit dieser Frage der
kommunalen wärmeplanung wird sich dann
auch klären welche Optionen habe ich
tatsächlich vor Ort das hindert mich
aber nicht daran alle Optionen die jetzt
schon da sind schon mal zu prüfen es
gibt wie gesagt kein pauschalen Rad in
dieser Frage weil es anders jede Vision
ist anders auch die soziale Lage ist
immer unten andere deshalb alle Optionen
prüfen und nicht in ein Gerät verliebt
sein sondern schauen dass die
Gesamtlösung passt und dann erst was los
treten ich rate also Ruhe zu bewahren
und tatsächlich auf sich zu Impfungen
was macht die Kommune vor Ort vielen
Dank Frau Professorin für diesen Rat und
für die Information danke schön nach
Siegen
ich danke Ihnen alles Gute
ja wir haben also gelernt für die
energetische Sanierung den
Heizungstausch bei Bestandsimmobilien
gibt es keine Blaupausen hier geht's
also immer um sehr individuelle Lösungen
meist teuer das hat inzwischen auch die
Bundesregierung erkannt und will eben
mehr Fernwärme die wird ja zentral
erzeugt und versorgt dann die
angeschlossenen Gebäude ein Beispiel aus
Heidelberg
diese Wärmepumpe füllt ein ganzes
Gebäude und ist sein ganzer Stolz
Michael teigeler von den Stadtwerken
Heidelberg will die hier gewonnene Wärme
ins städtische Fernwärmenetz einspeisen
zentral und klimaschonend erzeugt statt
in vielen kleinen Geräten zu Hause der
kommunale Plan zur Wärmeversorgung hier
wird er schon in wenigen Monaten fertig
sein denn Baden-Württembergs
Landesregierung setzt sogar einen
strengeren Zeitplan als der Bund auch
Energie aus Biomasse wie Holzabfällen
oder Biogas sind in Heidelberg Teil des
Konzepts solche Pläne will die
Bundesregierung nun zur Bedingung machen
erst wenn es sie gibt sollen auch die
öko-vorschriften für die Heizungen in
Haushalten greifen eine Strategie die
die Stadtwerke hier begrüßen
es ist wichtig dass die Menschen wissen
was kommt das ist auch richtig so dass
jetzt das Kabinett genau diese
Reihenfolge vorgesehen hat nämlich erst
den kommunal wärmeplanung schaffen und
dann die Verpflichtungen für die Bürger
zu geben doch der Ausbau der wärmelnetze
und deren Umstellung auf
klimaschonendere Energiequellen wird
sehr viel Geld kosten in Heidelberg
rechnen sie mit weiteren 800 Millionen
Euro hier haben Sie zum Beispiel diesen
55 m hohen Turm gebaut ein Speicher voll
mit heißem Wasser Investitionen die der
Bund fördert aber ist der Fördertopf
auch groß genug Zweifel in Heidelberg
dann würde man deutschlandweit etwa
zehnmal Heidelberg schaffen und das wird
nicht reichen das heißt wir müssen äh
die Förderung auch vom Bund dann
langfristig auch über das Jahr 2026
gesichert haben und auch in der Höhe
muss es den Zielen angepasst sein
in Heidelberg ist das gemeinsame
Wärmenetz mit Mannheim schon heute eines
der größten Deutschlands bis spätestens
2028 sollen nun alle größeren Städte
wärmepläne vorlegen müssen doch Experten
warnen die Bundesregierung schaffe
keinen Anreiz diese Pläne besonders
schnell zu entwickeln denn ausgerechnet
wo es schnell geht könnten die strengen
öko-vorgaben für Heizungen in Haushalten
zuerst eingeführt werden das darf aus
meiner Sicht nicht sein dass die
Vorreiter Kommunen bestraft werden die
jetzt schon werden Planung haben dass
die Bürgermeister und Bürgermeisterin
quasi den Druck den Streit aus Berlin
abbekommen da muss das Parlament eine
gute Lösung finden
und genauso ist es auch in Heidelberg
die wärmeplanung ist fast fertig die
Umsetzung läuft auf Hochtouren und das
heißt für alle die nicht am Wärmenetz
hängen die ökovorgaben für die
Hausheizung kommen hier möglicherweise
früher als andersrum
Fernwärme für die Zukunft das macht
natürlich nur Sinn wenn sie aus
erneuerbaren Energien kommt bislang
liegt der Anteil bei rund 20 Prozent das
muss mehr werden auch das ein Ergebnis
des fernwärmegipfels vom Juni 2023 dort
haben sich Minister Habeck und
Vertreterinnen der Kommunen auf einen
Anteil von mindestens 50% bis 2023
verständigt so das Klimaziel und die
Fernwärme soll natürlich massiv
ausgebaut werden bislang ist ein
Anschluss erst für rund 15% der
Wohnungen in Deutschland möglich Zahlen
über die man in Rostock nur schmunzeln
kann in der Hansestadt hat Fernwärme
eine lange Tradition
ein Rohrnetz von 800 km Länge versorgt
Rostock mit Fernwärme noch gewinnen die
Stadtwerke diese hauptsächlich aus
fossilen Energiequellen ab Herbst nehmen
Sie hier die sogenannte power to
heat-anlage in Betrieb und setzen auf
grüne Quellen für den Koordinator von
Rostocks wärmeplanung wichtig damit
müssen etwa Offshoreanlagen bei Sturm
künftig nicht mehr abgeschaltet werden
wir können also hier die
stromüberschüsse die durch Wind und
Sonne hier in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
sehr häufig anfallen sinnvoll nutzen
indem wir daraus werden machen
Fernwärme besonders für Großstädte
geeignet in Deutschland werden damit
acht Prozent der Privathaushalte
versorgt in Rostock sind es 60 Prozent
ein Vorsprung aus der DDR-Zeit als Geld
für fossile Brennstoffe knapp war ganze
Viertel sind in der Hansestadt seit
damals angeschlossen man ist es nicht
anders gewöhnt ne so sage ich mal man
kennt ja nichts anderes eine Zeit lang
war ja fern werden ja auch immer noch
günstiger als Flüssiggas vorher schon
vor dieser ganzen Krise Filme
haben aber ich lebe meine Gasheizung so
lange wie sie geht mehr Fernwärme so
schnell wie möglich ein logistischer
Kraftakt nicht nur für Rostock das ist
ein großer Personalbedarf auch mit damit
verbunden diesen Prozess zu organisieren
zu steuern da würden wir uns wünschen
dass im Gesetz noch mal eine Aussage
dazu getroffen wird wer das dann
finanziert wo kommen die Leute her wo
kommt das Geld für die Leute her
bis 2035 will Rostock weg von der
Abwärme aus Kohlekraft und 80% der
Fernwärme klimaneutral erzeugen das wird
sportlich sagen sie in der Hansestadt
die Zukunft der Fernwärme in Deutschland
darüber kann ich jetzt sprechen mit
Professor Manfred fischedicke ist
Energie und Klimaforscher und Präsident
und Geschäftsführer des
wuppertal-institut für Klima Umwelt-
hallo grüß sie ja ich habe ein bisschen
nachgeguckt und recherchiert vor unserem
Gespräch und eine Veröffentlichung unter
anderem von ihnen gefunden von 2007 die
da schon hieß Potenziale für Fernwärme
in Deutschland also welche Rolle spielt
die kommunale wärmeplanung jetzt für die
Energiewende
ist das wissen wir jetzt nicht seit
heute sondern das wissen wir eigentlich
schon seit 20 Jahren wenn man hat immer
gucken will wissen wie es eigentlich
schon seit 40 Jahren das ist die
entscheidende Voraussetzung dafür um den
Bürger den BürgerInnen auch ihre
Entscheidungsmöglichkeiten das ist
einfacher zu machen denn dort wo werden
wir mal eingesetzt werden kann oder wo
na wenn man jetzt
anschließen kann da braucht man sich da
nichts zwingend Gedanken zu machen über
ein eigenes Heizungssystem also wenn ist
das der erste wichtige Schritt bevor man
eine weitere Schritte sich überlegt wie
realistisch sehen Sie denn das Ziel bis
2030 Fernwärme schnell auf erneuerbare
Energie umzusteigen
wir müssen jetzt zwei Dinge gleichzeitig
machen auf der einen Seite müssen die
Ferne Systeme ausbauen das machen Städte
die Sie gerade gezeigt haben oder auch
Stelle die Köln wie Mannheim machen das
Beispiel was in München machen das
müssen wir raus bauen an den Rändern ein
Stückchen weiter die die Fernwärme
verstärkt nutzen die im Innenraum
verdichten dass die erste Voraussetzung
und die zweite ist dann tatsächlich den
fern oder Mix also den Wärme Mixer
dahinter steht zu verändern die heute
das haben sie im Material auch genannte
sehr stark noch raus Heizkraftwerken
kommt die Fossil Betrieben sind wir
müssen wir auf erneuerbare Energien
umsetzen auch Solarthermie auf Erdwärme
industrielle Wärme nutzen aber die ganze
Reihe von Möglichkeiten die man jetzt
nicht schließen muss das fällt nicht vom
Himmel sondern dafür brauchen wir die
nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahre dann halte
ich das durchaus möglich
für wen ist denn dieses Konzept
Fernwärme sind voll klar sie haben es
eben schon gesagt natürlich eher für die
Ballungsgebiete für die großen Städte wo
man eben auch eher engem Raum viele
Anschlüsse hat aber man macht sich ja
auch ähm wenn man jetzt Fernwärme
bezieht sehr abhängig von einem einzigen
Anbieter
braucht dafür klare regulatorische
Rahmenbedingungen so dass die Kosten
auch in Grenzen gehalten werden ist
diejenigen die sich anschließen an die
Fernwärme noch eine Sicherheit haben
dass sie nicht Union werden wenn man so
und wenn man so will und das ein
bisschen drastisch formulieren
formulieren will leider haben wir den
Vergangenheit ein paar Beispiele gesehen
wo das nicht so gut geklappt hat das ist
unser Gesetzgeber gefragt auf der
anderen Seite ist ja der große Vorteil
der Ferne wenn wir das hier
unterschiedliche Wärmequellen nutzen
können also flexibel sein können
unterschiedliche Quellen ist gleiche
Netz einspeisen können das heißt die
Abhängigkeit ist da ein Stückchen weit
geringer als wenn man sich jetzt nicht
Erdgasheizung oder sogar eine
Wasserstoff Heizung in die Keller setzen
würde das ist nur Option eine gute
Option für die Zukunft
auch sie bleiben uns noch weiterhin
zugeschaltet wir schauen uns allerdings
erst mal gemeinsam einen Beitrag von
einem unserer Nachbarländer an der Blick
über den Tellerrand ich habe es ja zu
Beginn der Sendung schon mal gesagt
Deutschland ist Schlusslicht letzter
beim Einbau von Wärmepumpen
in Europa weit vorne dabei sind die
skandinavischen Länder was machen die
anders was können wir lernen Beispiel
Dänemark
Sahara 2D unpassender könnte die Adresse
nicht sein im Hafen von Esbjerg in
dieser schwarzen Halle entsteht die
Zukunft der Energieversorgung für die
dänische Küstenstadt
hier bauen Techniker eine der
weltgrößten Wärmepumpen sie zieht Wärme
aus dem Meer und speist sie ins
Heizungssystem ein
die Umstellung auf erneuerbare Energien
hat uns sehr beschäftigt wir wollten
eine nachhaltige Lösung zur
Wärmeerzeugung finden und dafür ist die
meerwasserwärmepumpe die wir gerade
installieren fantastisch
jasper frostrasmussen ist Bürgermeister
der kleinen Hafenstadt an der Westküste
Dänemarks als Ingenieur versteht er
etwas von Ökostrom und Fernwärmenetzen
Wärmepumpe statt Öl und Gas davon sind
sie hier überzeugt
zwei Drittel der Haushalte in Dänemark
sind an das Fernwärmenetz angeschlossen
das heißt Sie können alle auf einmal
durch die Wärmepumpe von Kohle auf
erneuerbare Wärme umgestellt werden ohne
einen Heizungstausch die Verbraucher
bekommen nichts davon mit das macht die
wärmewende so erfolgreich
ob große oder kleine Ausführung
Wärmepumpen funktionieren im Kern alle
gleich sie ziehen Wärme aus der Umgebung
und Speisen sie ins Heizsystem ein das
Modell in espia nutzt die Wärme von
Meerwasser mit Hilfe des Kühlmittels CO2
das flüssige CO2 zirkuliert in der
Wärmepumpe verdampft zu Gas und nimmt
dabei die Wärme des Meerwassers auf es
läuft dann durch einen Verdichter wird
komprimiert und erhitzt sich weiter in
einem Kondensator wird es wieder in
einen flüssigen Zustand gebracht die
dadurch entstandene Heizenergie wird
schließlich in das Fernwärmenetz
übertragen
der Vorteil der Wärmepumpe ist sie
liefert preiswerte Wärme da sie mit
grünem Strom betrieben wird und der ist
günstig in Dänemark da wir viel
windkraft und Solarenergie haben die
Preise sinken das ist dann auch gut für
den Endverbraucher
normale Wärmepumpen fürs Einfamilienhaus
kommen auf rund 0,015 Megawatt Leistung
die mehr Wasserwärmepumpe in espia hat
rund 70 MB solche großwärmepumpen sind
in Skandinavien schon seit Jahrzehnten
im Einsatz
die Skandinavier haben das Thema
wesentlich stärker Betrieben Anfang der
80er Jahre des letzten Jahrhunderts und
haben große Wärmepumpen installiert die
größten Wärmepumpen heute stehen in
Göteborg in Stockholm in Helsinki da
reden wir über mehrere Megawatt die
installiert sind und die heute Wärme und
Kälte bereitstellen
sorgt ein Kohlekraftwerk für warme
Wohnungen das soll nun abgeschaltet
werden
60.000 Tonnen CO2 spart die Stadt
essberg jährlich ein durch ihre neue
großwärmepumpe so viel wie bei 40.000
Kleinwagen mit Verbrennungsmotor anfällt
gebaut hat sie das deutsche Unternehmen
ich muss erstmal die Basis schaffen
sprich erneuerbare Energie muss
vorhanden sein weil sonst macht es ja
keinen Sinn wenn ich Strom aus
Kohlekraftwerken benutze um eine
Wärmepumpe anzutreiben dann bin ich am
Ende des Tages nicht CO2 neutral das
heißt hier muss erstmal die Basis gelegt
werden Ausbau von erneuerbaren
Energiequellen um dann so eine große
Wärmepumpe auch betreiben zu können
esberg will bis 2030 klimaneutral sein
demnächst soll hier einer der
weltgrößten elektrolyseure gebaut werden
um grünen Wasserstoff herzustellen der
Hafen ist schon heute der größte
europäische Umschlagplatz für Offshore
Windenergieanlagen
ich bin ganz klar der Meinung dass
kritische Infrastruktur in der
öffentlichen Hand bleiben muss denn es
ist einfach entscheidend dafür dass man
so die gesellschaftlichen
Herausforderungen angehen kann zum
Beispiel bei der Energiewende etwa bei
Strom oder Heizenergie oder was man
sonst angehen will
den deutschen Streit um die Wärmepumpe
versteht man in Dänemark nicht bereits
seit 2013 sind dort Öl und Gasheizungen
in Neubauten Tabu in Deutschland sind
großwärmepumpen für Fernwärme gerade mal
angedacht
in Deutschland werden Nahwärmenetze oft
mit Kraft wärmekopplung betrieben und
man hat sich bisher nicht sehr darum
gekümmert ob die Wärme die nah wenn man
jetzt geht grün ist und das muss ich
jetzt ändern wir haben wenn wir die
großwärmepumpen in Narbe im letzten
einsetzen ein sehr extrem hohen Hebel um
sehr schnell große Mengen von Energie
Grün zu machen und das kann die
Wärmepumpe leisten
Berg und Umgebung jedenfalls werden ab
Oktober 100.000 Menschen komplett von
Kohle auf grüne Fernwärme aus der
Meerwasser Wärmepumpe umgestellt
Ciao deutsche Technik in Dänemark haben
wir gesehen Professor Fische dick
Dänemark verfolgt die Energiewende im
Gebäudesektor ja schon sehr lange und
konsequent wieso haben wir das in
Deutschland verschlafen
der ist eine gute Frage werden
tatsächlich an Dänemark lernen können
die schon 70er Jahren oder ölpreis-krise
konsequent auf einer Abkehr der
Verbrennung von Öl gesetzt haben die
schon Ende der 70er Jahre auch die
verpflichtende kommunale wärmeplanung
eingeführt haben die
CO2-Preise haben die noch ein Anreiz
setzen Ihre Heizung zu ändern die
entfernen wir mal Ausbau haben die sie
wirklich sehen lassen kann sind die
Zahlen ja zum Teil genannt Dänemark weit
mehr 60% stecken die Kopenhagen fast 98%
werden ich glaube wir waren einfach in
Deutschland nicht nicht mutig genug
diese Energiequelle Fernwärme
tatsächlich breiter in die Versorgung
reinzubringen vielleicht weil wir die
Infrastruktur nicht ausbauen wollten
alles Investment gestört ähm nicht nicht
tragen tragen wollten also Lernobjekte
hatten wir genug der Motor vielleicht
gefehlt dann sowas braucht Zeit und
dauerhaftes bemühen so
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen durchzuführen und
deswegen was anderes als wenn ich mal
eben
eine Heizung in dem Gebäude oder wie
austauschen
die Energiewende wird vorangetrieben im
Moment von der Bundesregierung mit wenig
Zeit die Zeit drängt und das haben wir
in Deutschland auch stark gemerkt kommt
in der Gesellschaft bei der Bevölkerung
gar nicht gut an ähm wie war das denn
damals in Dänemark ist da dieser Umstieg
diese Energiewende auch auf so großen
Protest gestoßen
natürlich gab es auch in Dänemark
Protest aber eher nicht wie jetzt in
Deutschland gab es einen Anlass es gab
damals in 70 Jahren eben die Ölpreis
Krisen das heißt Öl war extrem teuer und
damit der Druck im Kessler da etwas
anderes zu suchen und hat dann im
konsequent an dieser Politik auch
festgehalten obwohl irgendwann in 80er
Jahren ja das würde ja deutlich
günstiger geworden ist hat man
festgehalten ja kommunalwahlplanung
eines gemacht das sind die Kommunen sehr
sehr viel gestaltungsfrei Räume gegeben
hat man hat zwar die äußeren
Rahmenbedingungen
auch sozialer ökonomische
Rahmenbedingungen aber die genauen
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten die hat man
tatsächlich der Kommune vor Ort
überlassen und das hilft natürlich nah
an die Leute daran zu rücken und damit
auch ein Stückchen weit Akzeptanz für
solche Oma Maßnahmen zu generieren die
Kommunen sollen sie ein Stück weit ja
jetzt auch in Deutschland richten
trotzdem die Frage können Sie die Sorgen
vieler Hausbesitzer verstehen dann doch
plötzlich möglicherweise sehr schnell
gezwungen zu werden teuer zu sanieren
ja natürlich kann ich die Sorgen
verstehen insbesondere vor dem
Hintergrund dass man den letzten Monaten
gesehen haben das erste ich drücke mal
ein bisschen flapsig aus nur
Ordnungsrecht
formuliert worden worden ist und ein
häppchenweise man sich daran erinnert
hat dass man im Grunde auch
Förderprogramme braucht dass man eine
Übergangsregelung braucht dass man
Ausnahmeregelung braucht das sind vor
allen Dingen auch sozialverträgliche
Maßnahmen ergreifen muss und das muss
ich um diejenigen kümmern kann die eben
auch nicht immer die Möglichkeit haben
Fördermaßnahmen aufzugreifen das Kapital
nicht aufbringen können da gibt es
Instrumente mit dem man das tun könnte
das hätte man durchaus alles als
Gesamtpaket veröffentlichen können und
dann werden glaube ich die Sorgenfalten
in den Gesichter der meisten Menschen
neulich geringer gewesen als in der
Situation wo große Unsicherheiten
tatsächlich aufgetreten sind
unterschiedliche Akteure in diesem
Wärmemarkt unterschiedliche Aussagen
gemacht haben das ist ja die maximale
Verunsicherung kann ich die Leute gut
gut verstehen dass sie selber vor sich
sind
[Musik]
letzte Frage mit einer bitte um eine
kurze Antwort ich weiß das ist schwierig
wenn Sie das Zusammenfassen würden wir
sprechen dann immer im Konjunktiv und
klar rückwirkend betrachtet ist es immer
leicht zu sagen was braucht es denn aus
ihrer Sicht jetzt aktuell um die
Energiewende entsprechend auch
gesellschaftlich verdreht verträglich
hier in Deutschland voranzubringen
wir brauchen diese kommunale
wärmeplanung gehe noch da wo man eine
man schon weiße welche Richtung man
gehen will muss man nicht bis 2026 oder
2028 warten da darf man früher sagen das
sind Gebiete wo werden wir im Monat wenn
die Chance haben das sind Gebiete wo sie
ihm keine Chance hat dann schafft man
natürlich mehr Handlungsspielraum für
die Menschen also mehr Transparenz zu
schaffen glaube ich ganz ganz wichtig
und das zweite was wir brauchen eine Art
von gesellschaftspolitischen Konsens das
war einfach deutlich machen Klimaschutz
ist nichts was sie die Bundesregierung
rausgedacht hat das ist eine
überlebensvoraussetzung von diesem
Planeten noch für dieses für dieses Land
und insofern müssen wir alle im Beitrag
dazu leisten und ich glaube die sind
Diskurs müssen wir führen die 10 15
Jahre von der Vergangenheit zu wenig
passiert ist die dürfen sich nicht
wiederholen und klar ist aber auch wenn
man jetzt relativ kurzen Zeitraum diese
Ziele erreichen will dann geht's ins
Eingemachte und er hilft nur miteinander
zu sprechen
Transparenz zu sein ehrlich zu sein und
miteinander in den Austausch zu gehen
Professor dick vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung zum Thema
das war unser Phönix plus zum
Wärmepumpen die lämmerakt aktuelle
Informationen rund um das Thema finden
Sie natürlich auch immer in unseren
regelsendungen Phoenix vor Ort oder
online ich bedanke mich an dieser Stelle
sehr herzlich für Ihr Interesse und
bleiben Sie bei diesem und allen anderen
Themen weiterhin gelassen tschüss
[Musik]